hello everyone and welcome to another
most exciting game from the super bit a
rapid and blitz tournament it's around
five again Chuck Norris with the white
pieces against onigiri after that the
game who lost to Vishwanath on honored
he faces the leader of the tournament
they're not only after day one but also
after the four rounds that were played
so here it's it's a really interesting
game so let's just dive straight into it
Artemyev with the white pieces opens
with c4 the English opening is on the
board we have c6 by Gary E 4 and now d5
transposing into the sort of a coral
Khan we have ECAP force on d5 see
chapters on d5 and now d4 again
transposing into the panel attack of the
caro-kann the knight to f6 and now
Knight to c3
we have Knight to c6 and Bishop to f4 by
Artemyev d captures on c4 Bishop
captures on c4 and now East six so all
this has been played before Knight to f3
and Bishop to d6 offering a trade of
dark square Bishop sand of course Knight
to e5 and I centralizing move for the
night and this game has been reached in
2010 Vasily when Chuck had it with the
white piece against ernesto inner kiev
where Bishop captures on e5 was played
and inner Kiev won that game but here
Aguirre plays the top engine move which
is just the castle so it is as of move 9
that we have a completely new game on
our hands so Gary castles we have
castles by Artemyev and now bushra back
to b8 attacking the bishop back for
later and also now threatening to win
the d4 pawn so Knight captures and
seasick will be captures on c6 and now
Bishop to e5
just centralizing the bishop now and you
could go for Bishop captures D captures
and trade Queens here but it doesn't
give all that much for black yes you
have traded it down but after now you
attack me five point and therefore it's
actually white who's better you have to
two isolated points on the Queen side
and your pieces are not doing all that
great you used to have to develop your
light square Bishop you can go to a six
so it would be it would be definitely
advantage of white so after Bishop to e5
we have Knight to d7 pushing the bishop
and Quinta eat you sink I remind you
you're welcome to capture it and keep
your disappear so a five by Giri
now with ideas of maybe developing this
Bishop to a 6 as the rock now guards da
six square not immediately as both the
Queen and the bishop regarding it but
you know as an option for future rook
eight D one and now comes Queen to b6
developing the Queen attacking the beat
upon and also now both the Queen and the
rook Guardi a sec square so you can
develop the light square Bishop to a6
blush back to d3 bar Timnath which
offers the bt o pawn but for the moment
giri is not interested in the pawn as
you could you could face some very nasty
ideas with Bishop characters Queen
captures a queen h5 checks so he first
plays Bishop to a6 which which prevents
this idea if white wants more than a
draw so now for example if Bishop
captures King captures Queen to h5 check
King goes back now we don't have Ruby 3
because the Bishop covers that square
otherwise this this rook lift could be
very very dangerous
this way you don't have it you would
have to go for a draw here after a king
check you would have to continue
checking here and we would have a row by
perpetual checks so after Bishop days
sex with h4i useful move again if if
such and such an idea happens you have
maybe queen h5 you if black pushes g6 at
some point you can go Queen g5 and
advance the H point to already attack
the black Kings defenses so rook a to D
8 by giri and now Bishop captures an a6
Queen captures and Queen to h5 bringing
the Queen into the attack and here with
h6
now just reducing White's attacking
chance also taking away the g5 square
from White's Queen
Knight to e4 now with ideas of well not
only getting the Knight to d6 but also
in some variations knife the f6 will be
possible as you'll see so here you
should go for Knight captures on e5 it's
a dangerous attacking piece if you just
remove it after D captures play Bishop
c7 the rook is nicely guarded and here
even after Knight to d6 which it looks
dangerous you you can just capture it
captures not capture so with this but
captures with the rook
and after queen bee five threatening to
capture and then if the pawn captures
you just win the Queen Queen has to go
back to the one for example and then you
just have a trade trade Andrew d8 so
it's a very long variation but in the
end the white ends up with a pass deep
on and black will be able to stop it
from advancing so here after 94 the best
option for a Giri is to just pick it up
but get replaced Queen to be five again
he might have some ideas of pushing f6
where the bishop would be trapped you
cannot move it because Queen captures
Queen
so artemiev pushes f4 and it's a very
interesting moment in the game because
now well of course f6 one out of six you
might you might think well f6 is more
complicated than then it just looks
because if f6 and then Queen to g6 comes
and now all hell breaks loose for
example if F captures on e5 d captures
only five now you're threatening rook
captures on b7 followed by Knight to f6
check which you know you will not be
able to capture with the G pony will
just pick up the rook so a very very
difficult position but then a giri would
have to find Bishop d7 check in to h2
and now just King h8 not allowing this
idea after Lowe captures a knight f6 but
it's hard to to allow such such an idea
like you have to think what about what
if Knight g5 then can I capture because
mate this is threatened if pawn captures
then pawn captures can I get a rook f3
fall by root 2 H 3 and a lot of
attacking opportunities for white and
Giri just doesn't feel like f6 here so
instead we replace Queen captures on b2
which seems oh there's all this action
going on and you just grab a pawn so it
might be that you know Gary spider-sense
just wasn't tingling or maybe it's a
it's a case of legendary fever or
something where you think that you can
just grab a pawn in such a difficult
position but either way feel free to
pause the video here and try to find you
know the the winning idea for our team
is in this position for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations on
having your spidey sense tingling and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's Bishop captures and g7
Knight to g5 also seems nice but the
black will just ignore you play rook f8
and you don't
threats here within the night and g5 so
instead our team you've played Bishop
captures on g7 now if you don't grab it
all your defenses just falls apart so
keen capture some g7 was played and now
f5 this is a very nice attack basically
you know a drowning hippo attack where
you just want to open up the F file open
up the rooks reach to the f7 pawn so
here get recaptured we have rook
captures on f5 and now we get the
disposition where you have to figure out
how to defend the f7 point do you play
rook F a do push f6 let's explore both
options as they are both very
interesting if rook f8 it Lulu Cafe
loses by force because Queen g4 check
you move the King King h7 now Knight g5
with check if you move the King just
Queen h5 Queen captures on h6 so can I
have to capture the night and now you
get Queen to h5 check King moves now
first capture the pawn Queen captures
with check King moves now Queen h5 check
King moves and now you grab the g4
square for a queen our after the King
moves the rook to h5 will be checkmate
so rook to f8 loses by force what about
f6 we just not allow the Queen to
capture on f7 well here you again get
Queen g4 check King to f7 and now Knight
captures on f6 very straightforward and
after Knight captures just the rook
captures an f6 and it's well our team
we've had it all worked out that rook to
f1 leads the mate for example King e7
Queen the e4 would check now you have to
move the pin again King d6 now you get
rook the f6 check King to d7 now you get
Queen to e6 check or if King went to c7
Queen captures and c6 is made right away
so you have to postpone it by a move
just king c7 and Queen captures and c6
will again be checkmate as the King
cannot use a v8 or d8 so rook to f8 or
FX lose by force so Gary found a tricky
move Knight to e5 to defend now the f7
pawn is guarded and also if you if you
capture the night then rook captures the
pawn here just to show it if pawn
captures you get real character Sundy
won with Czech Queen captures and now
Bishop captures on e5 will be sufficient
for
for black to survive the attack because
after Queen to g4 you just fight King h8
and now if root captures on f7 yes it
does look dangerous but Queen a1 check
now wins for black you cannot go to h2
the bishop covers that square you have
to block with the rook and then you get
Bishop d4 check now if you move the King
you lose the rook so you have to block
with the night but then now just
captures captures and rook F a to check
will pick up the rook and now you're
just down the rook and of course black
is completely winning so after Knight to
e5 Artemia doesn't like pawn captures
but her rather rook captures on e5 he
again recognizes that black is well
either getting made it or he's gonna
suffer severe material loss Bishop
captures 95 Queen captures on e5 with
check King the f8 and now first you have
to get rid of the h6 point free the g5
square for your knight that's our
teammates plan of attack Queen a trait
check King to e7 and Queen to f6 check
so now what do you do if you go here
then you're lost because of a very very
sneaky idea and that's nice the c5 check
King to c7 or ca doesn't really matter
and now Queen to f5 wit check and now
you cannot use any of these squares if
you use any of these squares then just
rook to be 1 as the Queen covers the b1
square will pick up the Queen so you
have to repeat King c7 but now Queen
captures on f7 with check King c8 and
now again Queen to f5 check King to c7
and now tonight the e6 check and now you
have to go under the mask well over the
night you don't really have any and any
good moves here again if we touch the be
filed and again rook to b1 just picks up
the Queen so let's say you go here you
open up a discovery check if King moves
and now you just take Queen f8 check
King b7 and you pick up the other look
as well and again you finish the line
being upper rook so after Queen f6 check
gira try to go in back King f8 but now
Queen captures and h6 with check freeing
the g5 square for the knight very
important King g7 and now Queen back to
f6 with the check if you go to d7 the
same idea applies so you have to go back
King to a fate and now Knight to g5 and
it was in this position on move 30 that
uh nigiri resigned the game and Chuck
Norris takes takes the
when grabs two full points and
eliminates a theory from leading the
tournament it was in round five in round
six Giri drew against Anand but
interestingly after at the end of day
two of the rapid section the leader is
anton core above now III know if some of
you are following the channel for quite
some time you know that I always say
that Anton Corbijn is an amazing player
a very interesting player and that we
should always look out for him and now
he's leading this well basically a super
tournament and he's a wild card in this
tournament both artemiev laQuan Liam and
I believe core above are wild cards in
this tournament so so very exciting that
he was able to do this I just came back
from Zagreb so I didn't have all that
much time I saw this game and I said
cover it and as I'm flying to Germany in
five a.m. tomorrow morning we'll see how
much I will be able to cover but you
know if I don't manage it do check it
out somewhere else so yeah here he
resigns because how do you prevent Queen
captures on f7 it's well obviously you
could try Queen capture Sunday to grabs
the pond while guards are seven but then
d5 just prevent it now of course if pawn
captures the Queen no longer guards the
f7 pawn if the Queen captures of course
you lose the Queen just row capture so
you could try rook d7 here but now you
get nice the ISA is extracting it and
rook to e1 is enough for a win it
doesn't really matter what you play here
rocky 7 just Knight c7 with check King
d8 you will capture here with chair King
moves Knight captures here you're up up
up a knight and the rook and if you
don't go for something like this Queen
captures you could also bring the Queen
back to be closer to the defense but now
you just add another attacker to the f7
pawn rook d7 adds another defender but
now rotate rate sorry Queen h8 is
perfectly fine King g7 now you just
capture with the rook rook captures an
f7 with check king d6 and now of course
Queen to e5 will be made as the King
cannot use these two squares so after 95
a beautiful beautiful game by artemiev
and a very important victory for him
which really ruins the day for giri as
he was leading the tournament up until
this point so I know you guys I know you
guys think that we are we
should give him more if he had to lolly
slobber Timmy but you know a lot slower
Timmy of every game he plays is a brutal
attacking game so I don't think more fee
more he had is something he needs he has
the the develop head it's perfectly fine
head for him you know more if he had is
more of a head that giri would get if he
would play an attacking game because he
doesn't usually play attacking game so
that that's why when we give them more
if he had in case you were interested
but yeah that's the game i do hope you
enjoyed it I would like I would like to
thank Mahesh Parra and crispy card for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos
serie thank all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
this nice tournament including the
feeder Grand Prix checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and yes still
preparing the next big saga so thank you
all I will see soon and have an
excellent rest of your day